it's almost like he's a vigilante of
sorts you know what I mean how many
times has your dad been arrested or you
have you guys both arrested he's been
arrested half a dozen to a dozen times
but they were all by design right you
know we went that day knew that what was
being arrested was part of the plan
there was somebody already there to bail
them out like you know okay back then as
well you know we were really seen as
like the cusp you know we're on the for
the fringe you know it's just my dad and
me in front of an aquarium protesting
there's nobody else there and so if you
get arrested that's gonna get the news
there you know and like how do you get
on TV how do you get this issue out
there it's like you do what you have to
it because back then there was nobody
protesting it was not an issue it was
always in the newspaper SeaWorld says or
bla bla bla aquarium says and the
dolphin project accuses we were always
on the defense like our word wasn't as
good as their word because they're the
experts because they have not you know
what I mean like they're seen as yeah
they have dolphins in their place mm-hmm
well we've totally flipped that script
now now it's completely the other way
around like and you know what's happened
in the past ten years has just been a
revolution and it took 40 years of work
to make we've made it now part of pop
culture for not to be popular to have
dolphins in captivity
we've been spoofed on Family Guy on
South Park on The Simpsons they've all
done cove or blackfish themed episodes
you know Harry Styles in concerts that
don't go to SeaWorld 50 million girls
the next day they don't even know what
SeaWorld is they just know God just
spoke there's a place called SeaWorld
and they're never going there you know
it's like so that's like when you hit
that level of pop culture we've just
flipped that script and it's like all
these places are just kind of a dying
archaic like they're built on a model
from like the nineteen fifties like a
roadside like biggest ball of tourmaline
see the big lumber
Jack C you know wiki watch e in Sarasota
like the mermaids dolphins aren't you
know doing performing stupid tricks like
it's all this model that's phasing out
where are we today in regards to
captivity of whales and dolphins in
places like SeaWorld compared to say ten
years ago it just depends where you live
like you know places that we're working
really hard like I'm working we have a
big project in Indonesia there I'm
seeing the dot you know it collapsing
and we're shutting down places and we're
confiscating animals but then you go to
a country like China they're building a
new city the size of Miami every week a
new city they're building from scratch
every the whole city of everything and
they're coming online and that city had
once to have an aquarium you know so you
see a huge growth of aquariums in China
right now huge really yes they're
literally building entire cities at once
right now and they're building them all
over the place and so you know they
building everything at once all the
movie theaters the aquarium the and that
there Aquarians popping up that's
probably the biggest you know right now
the main most famous exporter of
dolphins is Japan and no that's where
you see that in the movie The Cove right
probably Japan is probably the number
one customer for Japan because they have
many dolphinariums I think Japan is like
the size of California and they've got
you know more dolphinariums in our
country does they have like 50 or 60 and
[Music]
and they're most of them are pretty bad
so they're disposable dolphins do they
buy them all the time and they get a
certain price when they sell them inside
Japan but when the export of China is
when they get the maximum price
which is like in the hundreds of
thousands where they're probably the
number two buyer of dolphins after Japan
itself
are they still getting up to like a
hundred and fifty grand for a dolphin
that goes into a tank for you know for
people to come by and watch it ties you
Japan Taiji's where they're slaughtering
him and there's a market there locally
in the village for eating dolphins
neighboring villages don't eat dolphins
it's more of a localized thing in this
village mm-hmm and so when you kill a
dolphin and you hack it all up it's
worth about $500
neat but if they take that same dolphin
and exported to China train if they
break it off and have some basic
training they can get up to 130 mm as
what we've seen we've seen it's you know
a sale for that much fur dolphin you
know depending on the amount of training
I'm trained maybe the thirty thousand
and maybe thirty thousand suprice inside
of Japan for the dolphin so clearly the
captivity is the underpinning of the
slaughter
because at five hundred dollars a
dolphin they really these guys couldn't
really sustain the lifestyle that they
have these are some of the richest guys
these fishermen in the village of Japan
Taiji they drive the nicest cars because
they're selling captive dolphins and
they're selling them for an incredible
amount of money and even in the movie
there's one point I think I remember
when I mean catch 20-30-40 dolphins at
once if you're thinking every ten
dolphin that they could potentially
Maksim get up that's one point two
million dollars every ten dolphin it's
like a date you know an afternoon's work
to go catch ten dolphin it's ridiculous
like between all the guys it's like a
pretty lucrative business and to me less
people are eating the meat so there's no
way they could survive on that it's the
captivity captivity that drives it and
what for people that are listening that
don't know about the The Cove The Cove
is the documentary and it's about a
place in Japan a very particular village
very remote and this village is the
birthplace of wailing wailing has been
going on there for hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds of years it's basically the
birthplace of modern whaling is in this
village but in the late 1950s they
started hunting dolphins so it is not a
traditional hunting whales is
traditional and cultural in japan
hunting dolphins is not traditional
whatsoever it started in the late 50s
after the war and they basically go out
it's twelve boats and they look for pods
of dolphins and when they see them the
boats will get in selected but form like
a horseshoe shape
and they'll have these poles that are
coming from the top of the boat where
they're driving the boat down into the
water and they go pull those and the
water it flanges out like the end of a
trumpet and so they bang on that pole
with like a metal wrench while they're
driving the boat in this horseshoe shape
and it creates a wall of sound and with
that wall of sound they drive a
dolphin's many miles from the open ocean
into the cove in Taiji and forever we
knew dolphins were dying there but the
way the landscape is where they killed
it opens you physically can't see it
they blocked off any entrance to it from
the road the beach you can't see around
this part where there we know they're
dying but we just couldn't see it and so
the code movie were able to finally
expose how what's going on in that Cove
and we were able to take we worked with
Industrial Light magic who does all the
Star Wars films and we made rocks that
matched exactly the rocks they have in
Japan and we had cameras in them and we
went with like a special ops team in the
middle of the night and hid microphones
and cameras everywhere underwater and
trees and drones and we're able to film
for the first time in high-definition
like what goes on there and what happens
it's a horrendous slaughter or they
basically just drive a spike through the
Dolphins head and what they're doing now
is they actually as soon as they pull
the spike out they put a cork in the
hole so the blood doesn't blow out so we
can't get those graphic images anymore
of the base filling with blood and
they've now taken tarp
they have wires that run across the cove
so they can run a tarp across a train
like a little sheltered area because now
we go there as the dolphin project we're
there every day during the dolphin
hunting season and with drones with
monitors were there every single day we
livestream exactly what's going on and
they try every way to block it and but
it's still going on it just ended on
March first and it right every year
still it's still happening every year
it's begins September 1st through March
and there's a quota they have you know I
think it's about an estimate eight to
nine species or seven species that they
actually get a quota per animal for each
species have
they're allowed to slaughter and they
try to meet that quota and then they
also have orders for dolphins and
they'll try to fill those orders
[Laughter]